die singen einfach extrem viel hey leute
und bekommt zu einer neuen folge ttc ja
das projekt läuft immer noch
es ist gerade folge 21 folge 20 war bei
spark folge 22 wird auch wieder bei ihm
seine bilanz halt abwechseln sollten
einige noch wissen für die die es nicht
wissen halt einfach den westpark
vorbeischauen wenn ihr die vorige folge
sehen wollt und wenn man daran denken
dann posten noch wieder video antworten
wegen der einfachen fall genau würde ich
auch sagen okay wir waren irgendwo wir
waren hier stehengeblieben challenge 9
und den anderen weiß ich nicht also die
stage stage neuen challenge im wasser
unter tel ich weiß nicht irgendwas mit
neuen zone b stage 9 war man glaube ich
gerade ja aber und einer grafikkarte
oder so prozessor stellen
ach komm das regt er noch immer immens
auf ihr kann er mal wieder hier zum
thema an schnitzen und zwar brauchen
können wir auch jeden bist du auch ein
star ist als ob keine ahnung was ich
dann rede ich sagen würde ich mich dann
höre ich rauchen würde oder was
natürlich kettenrauchen ich habe es
geschafft
check point sommer jetzt bin ich jede
alles schafft im winter setzen was du
hier die ganzen dinge abgeräumt das will
ich dran oder was sie haben unglaubliche
moment ich habe vorhin gerade geschafft
nun die wollte da minecraft nicht so wie
leute guckt euch diesen letzten sprung
an
aber ich hab's geschafft mit drehung das
war nicht nur eine dass man locker 1000
also wir können ja übers rauchen reden
es gibt ja also was mir aufgefallen ist
bei erwachsenen gibt es echt eine menge
die rauchen und wird das wundert ein
echtes wenn die einer braucht irgendwie
so ja ok nimmt man halt zu hin
aber wenn man irgendwie so jugendliche
rauchen sieht finde ich das schon
irgendwie schlimmer weil vor allem in
den jungen jahren zum beispiel in der
pubertät wo man dann irgendwie noch nie
die lunge und die organe quasi alle
wachsen und ich sag mal generiert
generiertes jetzt blöd sind halt noch
allem aufbau ist das natürlich das
schädlichste was man machen kann mit
rauchen
wenn man dadurch die komplette lunge
geschädigt und naja ok hat so prinzip
ist das völlig wurst was macht auch im
erwachsenenalter sommer noch schädlich
ja aber ich meine halt vor allem im
kinderalter ist es noch schlimmer weil
das wachstum wird dadurch natürlich
einerseits beeinträchtigt also wenn man
wächst nicht mehr so viel und vor allem
die komplette lunge da kommt natürlich
terrain durch die zigarette und sowieso
am ende kannst du deine lunge mit 40 die
straße deren so nach dem motto rio
flachwitze von smartphones heute ist
halt sehr dass ich wollte nächsten
springen im sinne von rtl aber leider
ach so genau
wertlos wenn er im rtl große tl das
entsteht für niveau wie auch gut so
warte hab es schon wieder geschafft
denn hinter dir und hat es auch
geschafft nein ich wollte vor dir ein
springen nicht nicht geschafft mich muss
noch kurzen apfel essen
ich machte meine checkpoint aufnahme der
reingehen ja ja genau war da warte ich
muss kurz raus ok danke das auf gemacht
hast auch kein ding bis er durch der
einzige der es immer schafft macht oder
die brocken moment weil die kommen hier
ziemlich gut voran gehe
ja wenn ich das so mit den kadetten
vergleiche so vier folgen bei einer
challenge mittlerweile geht es
eigentlich manchmal wenn die letzte
folge die eine beendet und die hier
angefangen jetzt wieder fast fertig
läuft schon schnell
ich bin fast ganz gut angefangen und
bringt die kommentare frage dass er gar
nicht die letzte mal gestellt habe und
wir schaffen das er zu einfach mal
komplett durch weil ich bin gerade
wieder fällig noch nicht ganz da die
eine chelsea zumindest meister ja ja das
wäre
das wird jetzt allgemein ebenso durch
schaffen in einer folge wir schaffen
jetzt noch die anderen wie viele sind
das noch mal acht challenges durch hab's
geschafft alter was fällt negativ machte
man checkpoint offene du musst echt eine
menge springt zwar nicht schwer aber du
musst menge schwimmen springen schwimmen
ja genau ich bin wahrscheinlich auch
noch her wo muss ich denn jetzt hierher
aber zurecht durcheinander jedenfalls
bei der map hier darf man sich dran
gesessen
bei der 13
ja also an alle die jetzt fragen ihr
durftet bei der letzten folge abstimmen
nein also doch dürftet ihr über welche
über die map die wir halt machen sollen
ob et 13 weitermachen sollen oder dass
hier ein t3 c oder das hier das ist gut
ein t3 c oder tutor historisches seinem
app in frankreich blabla aber die dürfen
jetzt nicht abstimmen in meppen
frankreich dafür dafür müssen wir erst
mal nach frankreich fahren ja natürlich
also müsste uns auf jeden fall dann ein
bisschen auf die werbung klicken damit
wir geld kriegen ja klar gegen youtube
mani matters lied ach so von von apple
pictures und so das ist vom amerikaner
ach so nee das mach ich nicht ich weiß
wenn ich kann nur einmal von vorn von
apple boss monster truck oder sony saßen
da um geld umgeschmissen man youtube
meine gesungen ich weiß nicht ob das
wahrscheinlich das gleiche lied ist ja
das ist wahrscheinlich das lied haben
die dann von dem ach so das kann sein
hallo es kuschelig warm hier ja schon
sagen das kalt ich wollte ich gerade
schon schlagen und sagen fall nicht aber
dann hast ja zum glück von alleine
erledigt du wolltest mich schlagen ach
so ja das messer weg schlägt nicht
schlägst du schlägst nicht bekomme mich
lag mal dass der konkrete die muss man
schnell wo ich bin weiterhin zuvor echt
entwistle hochgekommen auf einmal bist
du kommst router immer noch internieren
aber ich mache ja ich hab dich aber
gleich gibt's noch eine geschwindigkeit
oder was ja wer ist das erst fertig hat
damit nicht wieder sagst du bist ganz
unten das war der letzte sprung oder du
bist böse auf mich sein ich hab nicht
gestoppt wenig gestoppt stopp noch nicht
gestartet sie ja ich hab doch jetzt
rechts auf dem bildschirm oder city von
da ist es nicht schlimm
als ich aufnehme zumindest besser
geschafft noch nicht gut da macht mir
gleich ein check mal offen
keine punkte sicher auch zu springen
oder platz ist für mich alles mal vor
krass dass ich noch viel moment wartet
dann springt wieder hoch richtig jetzt
noch einholen aber ihr
bundesverdienstkreuz
begründung spark eingeholt natürlich
seien jedoch soll das noch gehen
es war wohin auch schon immens hoch das
ist echt krass
ich bin jetzt noch mal so hoch gekommen
wie du für immer gefallen bist gerade
und vor allem ohne fehler muss bedenken
sagen wir ich runtergefallen sagen wir
ich habe mich fallen gelassen
ausschließlich irgendwie schöner und
skilled voller an ehrenvoller wie
williamson das ohne fehler bitteschön
nach neuen rekord aufgestellt für mich
ich hab's geschafft
moment ich schaff das jetzt auch okay
ich mache schon mal weiter in den kannst
du schon mal dann soweit durch probieren
ich hab ich dann auch schon die nächste
ja genau muss mich dadurch noch ein ich
dachte das wäre der ausgang und da war
dann springe ich nebenher ein nein ja
ich war schon ziemlich weit oben
das ärgert mich jetzt aber egal machst
du offen er ist schon längst offen
okay und ich bin schon ziemlich weit
sagen wie meine freunde seid ihr spanish
course racing ist eine abdichtung davon
ich glaube ich hat gar nicht richtig
doch da bist du ja und liga daneben muss
erstmal abgelassen
schön sagen 'es ist zugelegt im sinne
von jump künsten vergleich zu vorher
dass bestimmte ganzer trainiert quatsch
mir beim jumpen gibt es nur ein paar
verschiedene möglichkeiten wie überhaupt
jumpen kannst was ich zwei blöcke nach
vorne einen blick nach oben
zwei blöcke nach vorne ein block nach
rechts ein nach oben gibt es unbegrenzte
möglichkeiten wie überhaupt schaffen
kann
wir machen alle ein paar mal so geübt
hat dann geht das eigentlich muss halt
einschätzen können ob du springen muss
oder nicht war vor schluss vor schluss
nicht untergeht 1
man kann nicht sein denke ich mir auch
manchmal denke ich mir gerade immer wenn
ich von ampel steht wenn man das kann
nicht sein
ich hab's geschafft übrigens erwartet
ubisoft jetzt spricht er wieder zurück
doch es hat weh getan
8a oben ich setze immer so einen gold
blocken
so richtig aber ein ja ja ja ja verdammt
aufpassen die ammann schwerter ich
kriege ja kein schaden ja ich auch nicht
bei mir blinkt das nur kurz ist ja auch
eine hammer rüstung wenn man es genau
bedenkt ja schon wieder zum beispiel
wieder runter gefallen so böse stelle
hier sparkasse ex-team hab ich nichts
gibt auch ein fake bei mir euro kurs da
bin ich ja gesagt ich müsste mir
vielleicht mal holen da ich mir gedacht
ja ist er wirklich mittlerweile so dass
man bei allen möglichen netzwerken
geprägt wird wenn man da nicht ist
mittlerweile sogar auch bei minecraft
ist echt so ich hab mir schon minecraft
dingen extras zwei ich hab mir minecraft
zu holen kaufte ich glaube schon ein
paar mal erzählt einmal nur meinen namen
zu kriegen kann und so ich hatte richtig
ist vorher anders so das wusste ich gar
nicht
wie siehst du denn ihr seid die geilsten
allmählich was dennis saarburgs gesicht
weil ich von minecraft mal im rahmen
sonst um gleich internetprojekt gekauft
hatte von einem kumpel werden so eine
web oder hat mit gaming website gehabt
hat gefragt oder nee das war einem
physik leistungskurs in der abiturzeit
vor
april in die im april 2011 in barbados
und er hat ja ich mache vielleicht eine
gaming website auf wie sich aus
herzebrock also bin ich auch zum kommen
unter anderem arbeitet gesagt ja warum
nicht
oder ich hab mir hat so erzählt haben
hier bietet ich hatte auch generell
nicht mal lust drauf könnte ich da noch
mitmachen so nach dem motto und dann nur
dass die salsa box net oder die seite ja
gemacht er hat sich den namen ausgesucht
heißt ja nix bekloppt ist sondern etwas
komplett neues also nur die spiele
deutschland in etwas quatschen sondern
die namen einfallen lassen was sonst ins
programm oder gibt da kann er kennt den
und dann habe ich halt halt artikel dazu
geschrieben und alles mögliche und habe
ich irgendwann mal gedacht
könnt ihr auch mal minecraft holen und
dann bin ich da erst durch zu minecraft
gekommen habe mir ein paar videos
angeschaut wie am anfang
ich bin die ganze zeit am anfang hab mal
videos zugeschaut und dann wo ich hab's
geschafft übrigens hektisch ganz einfach
ganz ganz einfach
minecraft gekauft
also ich dachte immer weil ich hatte so
einen typen gesehen da hieß die geile
nummer eins zwei drei
das vordach das doch der spark ist doch
nichts
ich bin jetzt auf station 14 grand final
am ende angelangt ist irgendwas
durchgemacht dann bin ich auch ich war
eine tat links zu hoch oder boa alter
guck mal hoch wie emails ja gar klar
oben kann nicht mehr ausgerechnet werden
weil du so ein ding ding ding und so
weiter nicht so gedacht hab ich doch
steht der lange weg warst penner steht
ein schild was uns das so sagt dass wir
das sein
ich kann ich genauso ich geb dir würde
mich doch ich bin gerade meer gesprungen
ich hab gedacht das ist richtig moment
ich bin auch richtig glaube ich bin ich
gleich den bogen raus und schießt sich
runde macht das ja also es ist auf jeden
fall ein rätsel hier hoch zu kommen also
dass man das gerät befindet hier sind
zwar teilweise so ein paar schilder mit
so einem fall natürlich nicht richtig
ist dann wenn man einfach nur nach unten
springt das dann natürlich suboptimal
extrem suboptimal
ich bin schon wieder oben doch das war
richtig nach hinten
ja das war wirklich richtig so
verwinkelt jetzt sogar schon schilder
platziert werden dann mit dem rest wurde
lang springst er ist auch die letzte
dinge final countdown single weiter
nenne ich singe ich verzichte man wird
du wirst mich niemals singen hören ich
will mich wollen die ganze zeit auch
hier mit glados cero wenn wenn ihr das
was sagt sie rufen ja genau ich freue
mich die ganze zeit dazu kriegen bei
denen mal karaoke mitzumachen
aber ehrlich gesagt nein es fand das
karaoke das ist wenn du singst nehme ich
meine jetzt gerade in gesprächen mit
richtig genug geschwindigkeit aber bald
von der wand gehabt da nicht mehr das
geschafft wo ich hinwollte
er ist halt ein flummi ein flummi genau
wenn du alles schafft und ich hoffe die
finale schon relativ weit oben
ich habe vier grad so relativ schnell
herr in einem durch die wollen karaoke
machen machen die täglich fast echt die
sehen einfach extrem viel scheiß
minecraft sport [ __ ] falsche ablage
drauf gesprungen tut mir leid das waren
emotionen emotions das waren emotionen
ja auch schon bald ernsthaft die folge
schneiden so richtig trauma tour
gespielt nach so einer dramatischen
musik bevor ich brauche gerade irgendein
opfer das sich schlagen kann
zwar komme her ich bin zu weit weg
übrigens in 20 minuten kommt ein bus
also wenn du dich überfahren lassen
willst 820 bei uns nett uns ist ein
bisschen spät kommen stündlich und spart
wenn du das nächste mal deine klamotten
weg lass dir gleich an
okay ich hatte letztens langeweile im
urlaub hab ich mal nach die besten
beleidigungen gesucht auch schon wieder
runter gefallen besten beleidigungen was
welchem sinn ja einfach nur so was ihnen
dazu einfällt jetzt nicht irgendwie so
arch
das waren da sonst noch so ach so dem
moment wenn denn die einer sagt du bist
hässlich ganz einfach sagen wenn du eine
frau bist ich kann mich schminken und
was kannst du gegen eine dummheit machen
moment ganz gerade so weit oben gerade
gerade oder sagst einfach noch nicht
stehe dazu problem damit ist eigentlich
total ab oder du drehst dich während er
das sagt kurz um dann wieder zu ihm und
fragst ihm redest du mit dir selber wäre
natürlich auch gut
ich glaube dass ich da nicht so elegant
aus wenn du dich einfach mal wo bist du
eigentlich gerade heruntergefallen von
ganz oben
natürlich blöd weil kurz vor schluss war
ich auch leidige sprüche benutze ich
selten ich beleidige kaum leute durfte
ich auch wegen der arbeit nicht weil ich
war ob sich dann wenn du ein
behindertenheim bis ihr kommt einer
gruppe spuk dann kannst du schlecht
beleidigen keine ahnung ich beleidige
jetzt auch selten leute aber die sache
feuer und flamme die leute beleidigt ja
es ja vielleicht in der grundschule mal
so edu pippi kopf kommt so ein kleiner
konkreter sind stöpsel an
schon die kleine kennt kraft nein ich
bin übers ziel hinausgeschossen
anstoß geben in der luft 8 dezember 17
minuten scheiße sagen ich wollte sein
kuckau das steht ja ich habe gedacht
der im blickfeld ach verdammt so nächste
folge beim spark auf dem kanal steht in
der beschreibung vielleicht auch morgen
als video antwort wir es beim nächsten
mal job